to do Wall Street Journal polls shows
the GOP getting a major Boost from White
Suburban women ahead of the midterms who
make up 20 percent of the electorate
this key group favors Republicans by 15
percentage points that's a 27 point
swing from August the shift not
surprising Democrats seem to be asleep
at Biden's events
are you with me
okay
come on people let's wake up we got the
president United States in the house
come on now she's like my favorite Marge
Simpson sister right anyway you know
what I think Katie I think maybe women
are tired of being called racist Karen's
yeah you know and having to you know
having to like be like okay I'm for drag
queen Story Hour you know they're just
like they're like we're tired of this
focusing and I mean there's a lot
they're tired of there's a few things
here you know when Rover v Wade was
overturned and abortion was sent back to
the States Democrats thought this was
their moment to keep female voters in
their their camp but people started
realizing when the temperature was lower
that it was simply available to the
states to make their own rules and
abortion didn't actually change in a lot
of the places where they want more
unrestricted abortion so that's one of
the things the other thing is of course
the school issue and the night before
Glenn yonkin won the governorship in
Virginia Randy weigarton campaigned with
Terry McAuliffe she's now in Michigan
again campaigning for Gretchen Whitmer
who said that she didn't actually close
the schools for that long right parents
are staying especially women are seeing
that their kids are behind they're
seeing that their communities are not as
safe and I think they're sick of
Democrats focusing on them as a
one-issue voter in terms of abortion
when there are other issues like
inflation crime and education on the
table that's a good point Jessica you're
a white woman or so you identify as is
this more about married women versus
single women because you have kids that
changes your filter Suddenly It's about
the price of baby food not the price of
an abortion it takes you know abortion
takes a backseat to applesauce is that a
fair uh assessment well married women do
also have abortions so that is something
to note it is I think that's a valiant
Point Jessica thank you it could be just
as murderous as single women sure
um I'm not going to fall down the Trap
of saying also that women vote how their
husband vote because we have seen
obviously that that has diverged into
smart women Jessica
got me in trouble
these were never our voters they swing
in and out depending on the election and
2020 had a really big name on the ballot
it had Donald Trump's name on the ballot
and that's how we were able to pick off
so many white Suburban voters who
typically vote Republican
um Dobbs Katie's right the timing of the
decision it felt when the momentum was
going our way and you had the Kansas
referendum
Etc like this was going to hold but then
conditions in the economy didn't improve
very much and crime became a superseding
issue to where abortion is so I don't
think it's something that still isn't
important to them but you're going to
have to rank your choices right you're
going to have to pick a lane and white
Suburban women I didn't expect a 26
Point swing but they're picking a lane
and it's not voting on a social issue
it's voting on a bread and butter one of
those I can see at issues like feeling
that Public Safety is not up to Snuff
yeah Dana it seems like those white
Suburban women like to swing yeah have
you heard about that yes yeah but on
Netflix Alex yes but I guess it's it's
brilliant isn't it mainly about the
price of things the inflation I also
think something that happened right
around then is that for uh women who
often control like the spending of the
household going back to school is very
expensive you've got the sports fees and
all of the things you got to pay for uh
that that was kind of shocking for them
and then you got to make the lunches and
everything like wow it's so much more
expensive than I thought I just feel
that the Democrats wouldn't recognize a
kitchen table if it hit them in the face
they've been talking about this forever
like this is not that hard and if you
think back to the year before in the
midterms New Jersey California New York
the Republicans were actually able to
pick up races in a lot of those places
this has been coming it's not something
new however I picked up something that
you might like today so we haven't
talked about Oregon and it looks like a
cup at least a few of the Congressional
races might flip to Republican but also
the governor's race and there was a
woman a mother who was interviewed and
she said her big issue is the following
what's your favorite word
problematic nope it is brown it's brown
yeah that's what your favorite emoji yes
she said her big issue is that she does
not want to take her kids to the
independent bookstore downtown and have
a guy
defecating on the sidewalk in front of
her children like she's had it that's
enough and I think that women
she should calm down yeah
Jesse I hope at this point that you come
up with an analogy that would make all
of us uncomfortable well no one knows
white Suburban women better than I do I
know I'm better than they know
themselves
the Jeep Grand Cherokees Italian food
Starbucks
J crew I mean Dave Matthews Band
Lululemon I got it all done Dave
Matthews Band that's disgusting and and
you're right they do swing they're up
for grabs they voted for Trump at first
in 2016 because he was exciting and then
all hell broke loose because he was too
controversial they don't like too much
controversy and then the quarantines the
whole family stayed inside the house at
the same time that was way too much so
they just wanted to go back to normal
with Biden he said we'll get us back to
normal and then he went radical left and
it was like Whiplash for these Suburban
white women because then all of a sudden
you get high prices in crime and what do
Suburban white men want to talk about
the price of everything the price of gas
home renovations and then the Suburban
white women what do they talk about they
talk about safety they talk about
schools and and shopping the prices of
everything so they get involved and
everybody starts talking and it's just
not cool anymore to be a Biden voter in
the suburbs it's a let's go Brandon said
situation it's just not cool the only
people in the suburbs that support Joe
Biden at this point are weirdos and
people with graduate degrees so if you
can just get things back to normal and
be no drama the white Suburban women
will love you
um
[Laughter]
yeah
I'm just letting it wash over me I know
how you think yeah why are you calling
them guys
he doesn't see gender I don't or race no
that's true